il y a eu vraiment une femme qui est
magique elle était policière qui voulait
me faire monter dans un taxi et c'était
clairement une tentative d'enlèvement et
de pour me dépouiller ça c'est évident
[Musique]
et bien je suis Antoine de Maximy et
comment me définir je suis surtout connu
pour la série j'irai dormir chez vous
que je fais depuis 20 ans et mais j'ai
fait plein de trucs avant voilà alors
j'irai dormir chez vous ça fait 20 ans
que ça a commencé et j'ai commencé
j'avais 44 ans et donc avant j'avais
fait plein de choses personne le sait
mais je suis descendu dans un volcan
pour aller prélever de la lave on a
dormi dedans avec des masques à gaz je
suis descendu dans des gouffres de glace
dans la calotte glaciaire du Groenland
sur la canopée la voûte équatoriale dans
les forêts d'Amazonie avec leur
adonissime qu'est-ce que j'ai fait j'ai
plongé en sous-marin 5000 mètres de fond
enfin bref plein d'expédition qui était
vraiment extraordinaire et j'étais en
fait déjà dans le milieu de la
télévision et du voyage et de l'aventure
puisque j'ai été au début reporter de
guerre ensuite
réalisateur de films animaliers et
ensuite réalisateur de films
d'expédition scientifique alors j'ai
lancé j'irai dormir chez vous parce que
j'avais envie de me renouveler j'avais
été réalisateur caméraman présentateur
in entendu son nom je connaissais toute
la technique et j'avais fait plein
d'expéditions qui étaient vraiment
formidables j'aurais pu continuer à
rester un peu sur les rails mais je me
dis qu'on a qu'une vie et donc je
voulais en profiter au maximum et j'ai
eu envie de tenter ce truc là et surtout
de retrouver ma liberté alors quand j'ai
proposé mon émission aux différentes
chaînes Télévisions qui en plus me
connaissez j'avais des portables enfin
j'avais eu plein de prix dans les
festivals avec mes documentsaires donc
c'était pas un inconnu elle va personne
n'en a voulu TF1 France 2 France 3
Canal+ France 5 M6 et ils ont pas refusé
une idée qui était un peu saugrenue ils
ont refusé les quatre premiers épisodes
parce que il y avait la petite chaîne
Voyage sur le câble qui avait dit ok je
crois que ce qui a fait échanger les
chaînes d'avis c'est tout simplement
c'est le public parce que ça marchait et
on le dit pas assez souvent mais c'est
le public qui fait les programmes alors
j'aime bien qu'on me demande comment je
prépare parce que en fait je prépare pas
je prépare le moins possible et voir pas
du tout là il y a l'épisode Vietnam qui
va passer je suis parti pour Taïwan et
c'est en arrivant à Taïwan où j'avais
prévu de rester 15 jours que j'ai
découvert j'espère que les gens avaient
le masque et que je voulais pas tourner
dans ces conditions donc j'ai regardé la
classe et j'ai dit bah le Vietnam c'est
pas loin je suis parti au Vietnam donc
je vais passer 24 heures à Taïwan et
ensuite j'ai fait un épisode au Vietnam
au départ le matériel c'était composé de
petites caméras qu'ils avaient fabriqué
eux-mêmes ils ont pris un caméscope ils
l'ont éclaté en petits morceaux et
j'avais des enregistreurs dans des
boîtiers étanches dans mon sac à dos ils
avaient pris les capteurs ils ont mis
des tout petits objectifs et ils m'ont
fabriqué des petites caméras haute
définition bah j'étais le seul à avoir
ça au monde encore là je reviens du
Vietnam c'est super sympa les gens sont
adorables mais c'est pas chez moi moi je
suis mieux en France quoi parce que
c'est pas simplement d'être avec des
gens qui sont accueillants ou dans un
pays qui est beau ou il fait beau etc
c'est les racines quoi de garder ses
racines d'avoir ses racines c'est c'est
hyper bien quoi c'est la mentalité que
tu connais parfaitement thé à ta place
je suis content d'aller ailleurs mais je
suis content de revenir les gens quand
ils parlent de leur perception de
l'accueil dans les pays je me suis
aperçu d'une part que tout le monde
voyait pas la même chose c'est à dire
qu'il y a des gens qui vont me dire tel
pays et pas accueillant et puis et
d'autres vont me dire ben si il était
super accueillant parce que ça dépend
comment les gens regardent alors
concernant la France est-ce que
l'accueil est bon en France moi je
trouve que il était dans la moyenne j'ai
fait ça à l'époque j'étais pas connu
donc sinon ça aurait pas d'intérêt et
j'arrivais comme un mec un peu de cinglé
avec des caméras comme ça et je voulais
aller dormir chez les gens bah je trouve
qu'on était dans la moyenne au début
quand je demandais à dormir chez les
gens le refus était majoritaire parce
que en fait ce qui se passe c'est que je
demandais à tout le monde il y a des
gens c'est pas la peine de leur demander
le gars le gars tu sens qu'il est pas du
tout dans le mood et puis en plus il dit
oui tu vas passer une mauvaise soirée
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui a pas de
relief qui est pas spécialement
intéressant et j'attends en fait que la
que la mayonnaise prenne avant soit de
demander soit de me faire spontanément
inviter parce que quand tu t'entends
bien avec quelqu'un que tu rigoles et
qui te dit tu dors où tu dis bah je sais
pas j'ai pas réfléchi gaidi bah tu veux
dormir à la maison donc je me fais
beaucoup plus inviter maintenant parce
que je suis plus délicat je suis plus
fin moi quand je voyage je me suis
aperçu que tous les trois épisodes à peu
près en moyenne j'ai un moment qui est
un peu tendu avec quelqu'un qui est un
peu agressif et tous les 5 6 épisodes
j'ai un moment qui est vraiment tendu
par exemple j'ai eu en Bolivie ça
c'était le 20e épisode il y a eu
vraiment une femme qui est magique elle
était policière qui voulait me faire
monter dans un taxi et c'était
clairement une tentative d'enlèvement et
de pour me dépouiller ça c'est évident
si j'étais monté dedans j'avais droit
alors j'avais l'expérience du voyage
depuis tout à l'heure 45 ans donc
j'étais plus un débutant ce qui a ce qui
s'est passé c'est que la vraie police
est arrivée qu'on a tous été embarqué au
poste cette fausse policière en civile
mais dans ton péremptoire qui me disait
on va aller commissariat gnagnagna on
s'est retrouvé au vrai commissariat il y
a eu 6 chaînes de télé qui sont venus je
suis passé en direct à la télé au
journal du soir
on sait très bien ce que tu voulais
faire mais je voulais rien lui faire
qu'est-ce que tu lui voulais alors à la
télévision
vous êtes français
et après ils m'ont dit faites gaffe avec
votre matériel etc je suis parti en
Amazonie tout le monde me connaissait ce
qui m'arrangeait moyen parce que je
voulais moi j'aime bien jouer sur le les
gens savent pas ce que je fais quand je
suis remonté à la capitale et ben là je
me suis aperçu qu'il y a des gens qui me
cherchaient parce que elle elle était
allée en prison un ou deux jours ils
l'ont libéré parce que il y a pas
suffisamment de preuve je vais te dire
quand tu es dans une ville que tu sais
qu'il y a des gens mal intentionnés et
vraiment mal intentionné parce que les
gens qui font des enlèvements c'est des
méchants qui te cherchent et que toi ton
boulot c'est de rencontrer des gens que
tu connais pas
c'est impossible bah là je peux te dire
que le lendemain matin j'ai pris un
avion pour partir j'ai dormi à la
résidence de l'ambassadeur de France
parce que moi il était hors de question
que je continue à me balader dans la rue
dans ces conditions tu vois alors il y a
eu d'autres moments comme ça
Sainte-Lucie je vais dans un quartier où
on sort festif que j'ai trouvé très
sympa moi et à un moment et je suis
rentré d'abord dans un espèce de de club
où il y avait les strip-tease
alors j'ai rien vu parce qu'à ce
moment-là il y en avait pas mais bon
j'étais avec mes caméras et tout bon ça
s'est bien passé au niveau de l'ambiance
pour le mec il m'a un peu un peu
engueulé mais bon il m'a laissé faire et
puis après je bois un verre avec un
couple mais adorable et là juste
derrière moi fusillade des coups de feu
etc
[Musique]
je le sentais
vous êtes sûr qu'on reste c'est pareil
ça c'est un autre type de peur parce que
quand il y a des fois parfois tu as peur
parce que tu as le temps de réfléchir et
que c'est dangereux mais il se passe
rien et puis là c'est l'inverse tu as
pas le temps d'avoir peur et de
réfléchir c'est une fusillade tu sais
pas ce que tu dois faire te cacher pas
te cacher les gens te disent de pas
bouger et ben j'ai eu peur mais après et
d'ailleurs je suis parti et bah ça ce
genre de de moments tu as peur
je me suis fait voler du matériel une
seule fois c'est en Éthiopie un sac dans
une voiture qui était mal fermé et je
m'en suis aperçu j'avais déjà roulé un
ou deux kilomètres j'ai fait demi-tour
et j'ai racheté le sac est-ce qu'il y
avait dedans presque tout ils ont gardé
quand même les trucs vraiment utiles
savoir
un vêtement qui tenait un peu chaud
parce qu'il peut faire froid la nuit la
gourde des trucs qui pouvaient leur
servir mais j'ai pu récupérer mes
batteries mes chargeurs de batterie
un téléphone satellite que j'avais à
l'époque enfin des choses comme ça voilà
mais je me débrouille je me débrouille
après un tournage je peux rester en
contact le problème c'est que ils ont
mon adresse et j'ai la leur moi je leur
envoyais la cassette après je leur
envoyais le DVD enfin bref en fait c'est
j'ai traversé leur vie moi j'ai passé
une soirée chez eux donc ça fait pas des
amis pour la vie et en fait moi je les
connais beaucoup mieux que me
connaissent parce que j'ai fait le
montage j'ai revu les épisodes j'ai
travaillé dessus donc je les connais
très bien j'ai des souvenirs assez
précis alors que eux j'ai vraiment
traversé leur vie donc dans les feuilles
il y en a quelques-uns qui sont venus me
voir très peu qui ont passé la parfois
même des nuits à la maison mais c'est
arrivé cinq fois alors c'est la question
de savoir si j'ai eu des relations
je devrais dire non parce qu'en fait
c'est arrivé une fois il y a 15 ans et
qui a pas couché depuis 15 ans donc
c'est vraiment une histoire il y a rien
à dire il y a des pays dans lesquels je
veux plus aller parce que j'ai fait du
reportage de guerre avant quand tu vas à
Beyrouth que tu dors dans la cave de
l'hôtel qu'on est bombardé qu'on se fait
tirer dessus que tu rentres dans un
village où il y a eu des massacres des
trucs comme ça c'est dur à 20 ans tu
penses qu'il peut rien t'arriver d'une
certaine manière tu penses que oui c'est
dangereux mais c'est plutôt les autres
ils vont être blessés tu penses pas que
tu que ça peut t'arriver maintenant avec
du recul et ben je vais plus dans les
pays en guerre c'est tout comment
réagissez mes parents quand j'étais
petit puisque j'avais fait une fugue
puisque j'avais fait ce film etc et ben
ils étaient un peu aussi cinglés que moi
dans un autre registre mais mes deux
parents étaient artistes peintres et
c'est vraiment des gens exceptionnels je
parlerai ça aussi dans le spectacle
c'est vraiment des gens exceptionnels
parce que ils avaient pas d'argent ils
ont vraiment jamais eu de l'argent ils
sont toujours on dit tirés tirer le
diable par la queue ils avaient mon père
il a fait un dessin avec des tout petits
traits de 1 à 2 cm entre croisés
uniquement des petits traits ce dessin
il fait 82 mètres de long c'est un mec
exceptionnel mon père ma mère elle avait
pas de quoi acheter des tableaux des des
cadres des toiles et ben elle peignait
sur les cagettes de supermarché les
cageots elles peignait et elle ne
peignait que sur les lattes et elle
peignait pas entre les lattes évidemment
et ben lapin des gens en prison pendant
des années et je te garantis quand tu
regardes ça c'est pareil c'est
exceptionnel donc quand tu as des gens
comme ça qui sont professionnels et
qu'ils ont un fils qui est un peu comme
si un peu comme ça il s'affole pas non
plus qu'est-ce que je fais quand je vais
en vacances ben je fais comme tout le
monde c'est à dire je fais pas la même
chose que le reste de l'année donc je ne
voyage pas je vais pas à l'étranger je
vais me promener voir mes copains en
France je suis très instable donc je
vais trois jours chez la voir même une
nuit et puis je refais encore 100 km etc
je fais des trucs comme ça et puis je
vais faire des trucs aussi c'est aller
faire des courses dans les grands
magasins allez à Carrefour à Leclerc
machin parce que ça je le fais jamais
donc ça me change les idées j'aime bien